I reject nation hey you guys sick of
Ridley Scott doing alien films you're in
luck
he's doing a political thriller you know
one of his in-between Alien films all
the money in the world do these do well
for him I can't remember it depends
really is really hit and miss for me
really is always hidden essays you know
you could do a freakin body by lies or
that one Russell Crowe living in Italy
lupus or then he does the Martian is
Exodus gods and kitties never know what
this guy's gonna give you you know he's
just trying to make as many movies as he
can he makes a lot of films
[Music]
[Music]
it's like what from another planet but
the force of gravity is so strong
[Music]
[Music]
I don't have any money
[Music]
[Music]
we have to show we're willing to walk
away I can't
[Music]
Wow
nothing
[Music]
it's like completely unrecognizable
there yeah whoa and the voice and the
body language the makeup on that Wow
good I don't know what the same guy
maybe that was an intense know what I
was expecting that's the thing is he
will commence it might be more of the
like it means a different tone but more
in the style of like when Ridley Scott
me like I felt like matchstick men yeah
yeah like those kind of thrillers where
it's like a lot of personality to it I
like the voice-over narration they had
in the trailer the turn of the Sun head
I'm assuming this is based on a true
story or a novel feels like one of the
two is getti
it said Jay Paul Gettys so I imagine
that's a real person that's who the
Getty Museum oh really
Balthazar Getty was an actor well I can
never be going to the Getty if that's
how he behaves nothing there's no ladies
yeah yeah powerful man here history I
just really admire the way that trailer
was edited in general the way how it's
like editing to the song and they start
shifting the way the songs playing out
like this slow it down or speed it up
but sorry mix yeah it remakes the song
and they remix the trailer I like the
all type of paranoid intensity when
character I just loved characters were
just kidding worse and worse watching
cycle over so much like Michelle
Williams why is she not more famous
why is she now she's like the best
actress around right she's pretty I
really think that well that was the one
thing that made me wonder about this
show because in the middle I started to
get a little pulled out when Mark
Wahlberg yeah because I'm like God my
polio because nothing is bad but because
it's Martin Walker yeah it's Mark
Wahlberg and that's a different thing
now than it was maybe back when the
fighter came around but Mark Wahlberg
has a quality where sometimes he shows
up and really Wow's me with how great he
can be as an actress sometimes he shows
up and I'm like you're Mark Wahlberg
yeah like some it takes a lot to see
past him sometimes so I'm curious about
that and it's only a small dose this
right
but just yeah the vibe the aura
especially like the the first third of
the trailer really one meal yeah like
mostly sensory stuff mostly kind of
setting up a toner in an atmosphere
along with the narration like I like it
I really bought into the lifestyle
because I thought it's gonna be like a
lifestyle exploration of this Getty
family yeah and then the son gets
kidnapped and I like that the first half
of the trailer really sets you up into
their world of being a Getty yeah and
then halfway through you start seeing
the world turn upside down kidnap even
such a powerful family can be rocked by
see yeah exactly
and track colors can fly yeah Kevin
Spacey man barely in the trailer but you
know everyone's gonna be talking Oscars
crap but just because it's a December
release IO pic performance boy can't
face it like when I was watching him
like yeah I was like well let's just
hear how he sounds yeah anything like
you know Kevin Spacey's Gilbert voices
it isn't often get to do voices in
movies true yeah and I'm really curious
about how he I haven't ever heard you
know actual audio or anything like that
so I don't know exactly what his
recreation of the voice is I'm really
curious to see what his performances
like cuz you only get a small glimpse of
it and I'm like here we go like this is
a heavy makeup like heavy you know
embodiment for form Oh totally and I
have no doubt Kevin space you can do it
and the makeup definitely wowed me the
first time I hope it you know can carry
through well he's really good at playing
you know powerful rich [ __ ] yeah I
mean cold Lex Luthor yeah nine lives
yeah yeah oh what's one more to solidify
with three great its Christopher Walken
um alright well yeah that was that looks
that looks like it could be a good movie
I like when they release thrillers right
before Christmas yeah don't front of the
people who don't have families on
Christmas to go and watch or no that's
what November is for Halloween is to go
out and have like fun and get scared
like out right and then November's for
like all right now
was just gonna be intense yeah I think
this is December oh is it
well are you excited for Ridley Scott's
all the money in the world or do you
wish this was the trailer for the next
alien installment which Kenny is your
favorite getting I like Bruce get
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell - on Twitter Instagram
go check out our patreon become a patron
eject today absolutely guys a lot of
funds consciously over there